foreign
I was fluctuating with my weight and
depression and she would just say like
oh you're too fat for my son and my
husband saw it where is he in all this
he said that's just my mom and she'll
stop dude he needs to step up man
[Music]
John with a Dr John deloney show
man I'm so glad that you are with us
giving us your time there's a billion
podcasts out there and you chose this
one and I'm so grateful that we are all
hanging out hey do me a huge favor
please please please please take one
second literally one second and hit
subscribe whether you listen to a
podcast you're watching this on YouTube
hit subscribe subscribe subscribe and it
helps it kick it up into the into the
algorithms and it puts it in front of
more people and uh man we want more
people to get the help that they need
and not feel like they're so alone
during these crazy times crazy times
um go ahead and hit subscribe send an
episode to your friend right send an
episode to your friend that'd be awesome
um and just above all thank you thanks
for riding with us and being in our
wacky little gang here man all right
let's go to Brian in Huntsville
Alabama what's up Brian
hey Dr John how are you doing I'm good
man things going all right
uh they're okay uh I've been married for
seven months and about three or four
weeks ago or right before Christmas my
wife told me that she hasn't loved me in
a year and is kind of regretting getting
married and she hasn't never really been
alone and she needs to try to find
herself and I just like I don't want to
get a divorce she did say she would go
to counseling but I don't really know
what that means I don't know what I need
to do like I want this thing to work I
don't think she she said things aren't
looking great I just don't know what all
of this means yeah that's my first
question to you man one dude I'm
I'm Shell Shocked with you let's catch
you off guard
I kind of had a weird fluke last year
but her brother passed away in December
the year before and I just thought it
was like like an anniversary just kind
of a hard time plus it was a holidays
but now she's just saying like it's just
she just out of love and just isn't
feeling it and I don't really know what
to do what to try to change is she
giving you an insights as to what you're
contributing to this or is this is
she doing the classic anytime somebody
says I don't feel I don't feel I don't
feel I always really want to challenge
that because man I don't feel like
exercising a lot it's still not the
right thing to just go eat donuts
there's times I don't quote unquote feel
in love but I still need to do the right
thing because I love my wife right
there's a there's an underlying
connectivity there that is way more
important than my feelings and so when
someone says I don't feel I don't feel I
always want to know
what are the what are the things that
are happening around you that are not
letting your feelings feel like you're
connected and safe has she given you any
of that info
uh she says I'm not well we kind of got
in a fight because she said she just
didn't feel like she had space and so
I just kind of was like well I can go
like stay with my parents for like a few
days and then the next day I just I'll
just some of them feel right and then
she said like she feels like nobody
really like listens to her or
and then she just feels like she never
really has figured out what she wants in
life
hmm but I don't really know like I guess
my thing is I was like you know the
whole time we were dating like she
was you know wanting marriage you know
we talked about marriage he was all on
board we planned the wedding and then
she's just saying now I gotta find
myself and yeah I like it I wouldn't go
I wouldn't go backwards right now
okay like I
it's easy to say
yeah but just like seven months ago you
said this what matters right now is what
she's saying right now
and you're all right to feel completely
hit upside the head like stunned by all
this because of what just happened seven
months ago or ten months ago
um but the important thing is right now
um
and it's hard to move forward with it
sounds like and so this dude I don't
have any like super clinical Insight
here it sounds like I've heard this same
refrain before a hundred times
almost without exception
either she has met somebody else
that has caused her either she's got
feelings for somebody else or she's
she's met somebody else and it is
causing her to doubt her commitment to
you or she's upset with herself and so
she's like I shouldn't even have gotten
married I wasn't ready yet because I
clearly have feelings for somebody else
which is dumb because you always have
feelings for other people I mean it's
just life
or
um she is through with this marriage and
she doesn't have the courage to say I
screwed up I want out and so she's gonna
slowly make you the bad guy over time
and the way she's going to make you the
bad guy is she's going to slowly hold
you underwater and when you start
fighting to breathe air she's going to
point at the fighting and be like see
look what you're doing
yeah like we rarely weren't uh fighting
I know she kind of had like a weird
childhood and I I mean a lot of I don't
care about any of that honestly I mean
she told you she was going to be with
you forever
and so now it's how do we create a
marriage and how do we love one another
and how do we help meet each other's
needs
and heal from what happened to us I mean
you don't just you know what I'm saying
like it provides the context but it's
not an excuse right
um
but let's let's look at the bright side
she said she'll go to counseling
um
you said you don't really know what that
means
well so you just very like pessimistic
like we talked yesterday and she was
like I mean if you want to move back in
it'll kind of make it easier on
everybody but I really just don't see
this thing turning around
what happened
I don't know we were like I just I I
don't know if I just got too comfortable
or
dude you've been married seven months
man
like that's kind of how I feel I'm like
I just feel like it's too short to fail
I mean even if she really fell out of
love a year ago I just feel like that's
like
like I wanted until I moved out that she
really kind of was like well I don't
feel like you know like I'm getting like
you're listening to me and stuff like
that and then she keeps trying to say
she's trying to find herself on what she
wants and I don't really know what that
means she hasn't really elaborated
and so I'll say in her defense okay
um
sometimes this idea that um I'm with
somebody and they're suffocating me and
maybe it's it's like like you don't even
know that you're hurting her or that you
are are trying to solve her or fix her
issues or you are doing things that make
her body feel unsafe what it looks like
and dude you sell I'm I don't think you
have a mean bone in your body like you
have no intention to do that but her
body's telling you I Gotta Get Away
Gotta Get Away Gotta Get Away whatever
that means
um it could be completely unrelated to
you it could be childhood's trauma like
coming forth now that she feels bounded
and trapped who knows
the
it can't always articulate what your
body knows and that's hard to be in a
relationship with somebody who can't
quite articulate like dude what is it
about me
that my presence says you've got to run
right that's a that's a terrifying scary
feeling for anybody because you love her
right
yeah yeah and like I don't I don't want
to make her feel like uncomfortable but
I feel like she has a hard time like
trying to express like what's going on
she's never really been big into like
deep conversations or like how she feels
that's always been a little weird well
and it may be that growing up you said
she had a weird childhood that
just like telling somebody how you felt
got you hurt
or got you made fun of or got you told
you to shut up because nobody cares
about your feelings and so you've just
learned she learned over x two decades
or three decades
to just bury them and now they're coming
out in full force because now she's
trying to create her own new home or
marriage it could be a a bunch of
different things
what counseling will do is
let y'all practice relationship with a
third party
okay it'll let you say things or that
person will ask questions that you might
either haven't thought of or
um you've thought of you just don't feel
like you can say it but when somebody
asks you in a therapeutic context and
you can say it and be like hey they
asked me like I'm not just throwing
grenades at you they wanted to know what
was in in the suitcase and it makes it
um it's an easier way to have that
conversation but y'all get to practice
saying something she gets to practice
saying something hard you hearing it
and then you get to practice breathing
through and asking how you can help be a
part of a solution except does that make
sense so I I look at therapy as
relational practice it's a way to
re-engage connectivity
um it does I mean it's it breaks my
heart that she's like I'll do it but
it's a waste of our time and money like
if I'm you I'd be like well crap should
I even do this I think you should
sounds like there's something else here
um here's how I would have that
conversation
I would tell her
I would ask your point blank are you
finished with this marriage
just point blank are you done
and I'm trying to ask her similar before
and she's just kind of been like I don't
know okay like it's not looking good but
she hasn't like I guess foliage tell her
that's that to me is not is is again is
holding you underwater and you haven't
started fighting yet in fact you took
these you mean you moved out you love
her so much you want her to be
comfortable so much you just took off
which good for you that's that was Noble
I'm walking away from a fight in the bar
you all have a great night I'm out of
here good for you
but that can't go on forever and so this
whole I don't know man I'm just doing
that man that that's you're gonna get
paper served on you and you're gonna get
blindsided again and so I'd sit down and
say are you done with the marriage and
this whole I just don't know yet
um that to me is not a good answer
okay
um I like are if you're in then we're
gonna go to counseling we're gonna try
to make this thing work if you are done
have the courage to say I want to end
our marriage
and I'm gonna do it I'm gonna file for
divorce from you and I'm gonna end this
thing
that would be I don't like that for you
I hate that for you I hate that for both
of you
but to do anything other than that is
just cruel okay I just need to find
myself and I need to go on a journey you
got married and so any Journey you take
from this point four you'll take
together even if you got to go by
yourself right my wife goes to her
counseling on her own I talk to people
on my own we're not doing that together
but I'm doing that so that I can be well
so that I can be the best husband I can
possibly be
like I want to like support her and like
you know if she needs anything or what
like finding herself looks like but I
don't really know
she hasn't really excited what that
looks like to her yet yeah that's
somebody's read a lot of internet
articles and has a feeling of I I'll
I'll say this let me let me just say
this I don't think I've ever said this
publicly in my life so here we go
um it was after my first or second year
of marriage I didn't think me and my
wife were gonna make it
and I was meeting with a guy we're in
the mountains of New Mexico I was
speaking at an event and we were
um somebody that I really really trusted
and I said I don't think I should have
gotten married I don't think I was ready
for this
and
he wisely said
that's how you feel but that's not true
and in his own wise way he was telling
me there's a difference between reality
and truth and your feelings
our feelings don't tell us the truth and
so you made a commitment
and now we're going to get to the bottom
of that commitment we're not going to be
led we're going to by our by a nose ring
being yanked around by our feelings all
the time
and you can't discount them our feelings
are great alarm systems they get our
attention they point us in Direction so
you got to listen to them and you got to
honor them and you have to acknowledge
them
and so I would tell you is I wouldn't
give up on this marriage I hope she
doesn't give up on this marriage even
though she's seven months in and feels
like whoa I just feel like I
go to counseling together
because at counseling you'll be able to
say here's what I'm feeling
and then a good therapist will say tell
me more and then tell me more
then tell me more and where is that in
your body and tell me more and you get
to the Crux of it
[Music]
and that's where the healing will begin
but this amorphous I don't know I was
going to find myself right man close the
computer go talk to a an expert
close the internets stop reading the the
whatever the magazines in the line
and go sit down with somebody and say
Here's what's happening inside of my
heart and my mind and my soul because
I'm struggling Brian let me know how
that conversation goes let me know how
your counseling goes man because I want
to um I want to walk alongside you guys
as y'all if you'll have me
um Joel figure out what's next for your
brand new marriage we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement and MLS ID
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housinglender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
all right let's go to Lynn in Portland
Oregon what's up Lynn
hi Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call of course thank you for calling
what's up
okay uh two very important pieces of
information you need to know whether I
forgot to put one of them in my question
initially I have borderline personality
disorder and I also have a traumatic
brain injury TBI what happened
I got hit by a car when I was 17. oh man
yeah is is the effects like or the
effects neurological are they are they
are they ongoing
yes it's permanent it was originally
labeled as severe I think when I got a
little older they bumped it down to
moderate uh but I do struggle with like
memory loss
um my uh frontal lobe was pretty badly
damaged so was my temporal lobe so a
memory decision making executive
functioning in general is not
um the best
you are an impulsive young lady aren't
you
[Laughter]
um Okay so were you diagnosed with
borderline before this or has this been
a result of
the traumatic brain injury
bipolar two which they should not have
done I was too young I was gonna say
good Lord
yeah and uh why I ended up going to the
mental hospital back in 2020 and that's
when they realized
um just so you know you have borderline
personality disorder and whoever
diagnosed you with bipolar did not do
their research
um
there's so many things here so many
things
um so let's let's go back so you had you
had a pretty chaotic childhood
yeah
kind of
um like my dad and my grandmother died
when I was pretty young and they were at
three months apart me and my brother
were pretty young I was I just started
Middle School okay hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on
I just asked did you have a pretty
chaotic childhood and you said kind of
my grandma and my dad died as I was
entering middle school so let's just
stop there
you had a very chaotic childhood
a painful traumatic childhood
okay
can we sit on that for one second
yeah it was hard huh
it was yeah it is
Fair
yeah that is fair what was your dad's
name
Chris do you miss him
what's that do you miss him
oh every day
so let's I don't want you to gloss over
it I want us to let's just it's as
uncomfortable as it is let's let's own
reality okay that's hard and then my
guess is
um
your mom was struggled a lot huh
oh yeah cause like my grandmother that
was her mom my mom was never the same
after my grandmother died yeah or her
husband right well they were divorced
yeah
uh was your childhood chaotic kinda I
came from a divorced home and then my
dad good night so yes yes I bet your
Aces what's your Aces score have you
ever taken that
I've taken what your Aces score
no I don't even know what that is it's a
10 question questionnaire it's the
adverse childhood experiences I want you
to take it when you get off my guess is
just listening to yours will be
a six or a seven you
your body has been struggling to find
its place in space since you were very
very little Fair
yeah and I bet as a child you shouldered
a lot of I can I guarantee you did
because just how you answered the first
question that whether you were wondering
why they got divorced why daddy chose to
leave when Mommy kicked him out what
happened to Dad why did Grandma die like
all that as a young kid
you were trying to figure out what you
did to make some of those things happen
or what role you played in some of those
things Fair
yeah sometimes okay
so then you have this traumatic brain
injury and what happened were you
driving another car were you walking
across the road what happened
um I was crossing the street and I have
to say it harsh was my fault simply on
the fact that I was jaywalking and I
lost was a four-lane road and I got to
the last Lane and I got hit by somebody
I went flying over their windshield and
uh yeah it almost killed me yikes man
glad you're all right
and so what took you to a um
to a psych Hospital in 2020.
I was living with somebody
um my cousin and we were drinking a lot
I mean I'm talking multiple bottles a
day and it got to the point where we
were just enabling each other and one
day I just couldn't take it anymore and
I was just in a very dark head space and
I realized I can't do this anymore
because if I don't go get help I'm gonna
slit my throat or I'm gonna do something
I don't know what but I need help and I
went twice that summer
um for both a three-day stay each time a
voluntary thought I went I chose to go
um so I could leave whenever I wanted I
kind of wish I would have stayed a
little longer at the time because I had
the means to do so I can't say I have
that now but
he's now I think about going back
sometimes hmm
are you still are you still
um actively suicidal
you know am I taking my meds my am I in
my routine little things like that to
make a big difference but okay
some days it just comes on and I'm not
even prepared to feel crappy it just
happens yeah I
um it's really important to me that you
call somebody after this and you get
checked in
okay
and that's just because I love you
and I want you to be all right okay
do you promise that you'll do that
I swear okay
um so how can I help you right now well
I have gotten to this point where I've
been
a bit out of control and by that I mean
I've been getting more aggressive
towards my partner I've been yelling and
screaming and calling them names and
getting in his face and and just not
being a very nice person to him and it's
affecting our relationship pretty badly
and
I just I just don't want to be like that
anymore okay it seems to be a common
Trend when I live with somebody some
conflict happens and then we're fighting
and yelling and screaming but I'm
usually the one who's fighting and
yelling and screaming right well and
that's one of the cornerstones of
borderline which makes it so hard is
this sense that you feel everything 100x
with everybody around you is feeling
so when you meet somebody for the first
time you kind of have like man I think
that I think she's she's pretty good
looking man and I kind of like her you
freaking love me I love you I'll sleep
with you right now and it's right and
and then when it's like a disagreement
like Ah that's annoying
you're like I'm gonna burn you to the
ground right I'm gonna kill you and your
family and and so it's this am I right
it's a thousand it's a thousand X for
somebody with borderline and that's what
makes it so hard is
somebody who wants to heal now I want to
hold a big caveat here you have a
traumatic brain injury if you've got
permanent damage to parts of your brain
this may be something that you wrestle
with for the rest of your life and
that's okay that's just part of it right
I've got I had a knee surgery like I'm
not gonna go play basketball anymore and
I loved playing pickup basketball I'm
just not gonna do anymore I gotta I'd
agree that it's a bummer now is that the
same thing as like uh
the hippocampal injury or frontal lobe
injury no you'll have more stuff to do
with but it's just it's just the cards
you were dealt and let's roll with it
right and so I hope you hear I'm I'm
speaking with that light of a yeah this
is the this is the cards I got right and
so I'm Gonna Roll with that I'm not
going to go to war against those cards
because all that does is make me and
everybody around me miserable the
challenge for somebody with borderline
is I have to choose to feel less
intensely
I have to choose to begin to parse
through our feelings and it feels so
good to be in love
and it feels so good to be enraged those
are drugs right and you have to choose
to like get off those drugs does that
make sense
oh absolutely it's so frustrating have
you been through rounds of DBT
dialectical dialectical behavior therapy
a little bit um my current therapist who
I recently got switched to he is
a little don't be a borderline Switcher
every okay every therapist knows that
when you get somebody and they sit down
they go you're the best
therapist I've ever had in my life my
last seven therapists they all sucked
they were the worst in whatever everyone
knows well looks like you got a
borderline here and you just gotta hang
on for the ride until you turn on them
how many have you been through
yes not very many um but pretty
um good relationships with my therapist
it always just came down to my last two
therapists had a different job or got
different jobs and they had to leave
okay you just made okay I thought you
were burning through them all right I
take back what I just said about it all
right all right I was wrong you were
right way to go so
um you got a new therapist and you like
him and tell me more
um he certified
um like he knows how to do DBT and he
does DBT groups at the my doctor's
office who hold a lot less intensive of
a program compared to like the Portland
DBT Institute
um but on our last visit he told me that
I should find a way to make some space
for a more inpatient I don't know if
it's impatient or outpatient but a more
intensive program because he's worried
about me he's worried about my
impulsivities and my um on all my out of
control out of control Behavior we've
talked a lot about it we've talked a lot
about the yelling and the screaming and
the and the name calling and just the
outright just his poor Behavior I've
been showing lately and it's are you
self-harmed
me no I mean no I don't like cut or burn
myself or do any of that stuff but I
suppose I self harm in the sense of like
I don't really dig into my hobbies like
I should I just watch TV a lot or do a
lot of monotonous activities because
it's all I feel like I have time for for
the energy for why
why don't you think Lynn deserves peace
they're on chaos my whole life this is
hard to feel like I can have some
quiet for a change yeah because when
chaos is your drug
peace feels very very stressful
I mean
and it's learning how do I learn how is
this something you have to practice over
time that's what DBT is you're gonna
have to practice
feeling enraged and letting it run
through you
and then going okay what's the reality
here this guy loves me he's not going
anywhere
um
I am enraged I'm gonna take a break I'm
gonna go for a walk
and that sounds bananas to you right now
because what you want to do is hit him
as hard as you can
and it's it's a choice that I want my
life to be more peaceful and I'm gonna
have to practice it I'm gonna have to
learn it because I've never even seen it
I don't even know what that I don't you
can I can say peace all day long you're
like okay
um it's like trying to explain a
dinosaur to somebody who's never seen
one like it doesn't make any sense I
don't know what you're talking about and
so you're gonna have to decide Lynn is
worth a less electrified life
and I need you to hear me say I think
you're worth that
you're a therapist thinks you're worth
that
and the crummy thing about being an
adult and caring about people is we
can't make you do that you have to
choose
and what I'll tell you is you have
exceeded your capacity to handle this by
yourself
not in those words but uh you're not the
first person to tell me that or at least
people around me are aware that I'm at a
heightened State okay
and that I'm struggling yes
call today I feel bad though my family
doesn't always know how to help me I
know but I always try to tell people
like I'm not expecting people to like
have solutions for me all I ask is that
you sit with me while I'm going through
it and I feel like a lot of people have
figured that out but I feel like there's
some people in my life that haven't
quite
checked up on that here's here's the
hard thing they get to choose that
they get to choose that and sometimes
our rage and our
are lashing out and are yelling and
screaming is
a way we can buffer sadness
because our bodies don't know how to
feel sad because last time we felt sad
dad moved out
and last time we felt sad grandma died
and last time we felt sad dad passed
away and last time he felt sad mom was
just checked out a zombie
and so your body's created some really
powerful strategies for not being sad
could you tend to find it a lot that
feeling try to numb it out with
something else sometimes it's a black
hole right
yeah and you can't go through you can't
go down that hole alone I need you to
hear me I need you to promise me you
will call somebody today
I will
no say I love Lynn enough
that I will call somebody and get help
today
enough I will call somebody today
I'm proud of you what you're about to
embark on it's gonna be hard and it's
going to be something you're gonna have
to grind through a little bit and you're
gonna be brave and I'm really really
proud of you
foreign
are you gonna hang up and be like that
guy's the worst podcaster ever because
that'd be a very borderline thing to do
God no no no no no no I I was surprised
you guys even picked my question I
honestly thought it was going to get
lost in a fee of a thousand questions
awesome I'm quite honored not really
good at what you do I'm honored that you
uh
trust me I have a I have a a deep heart
for
folks with borderline
because it's a tough tough tough road to
Hope and the thing that you need more
than anything is peace and relationships
and the hardest thing in the world to
come by is peace and relationships and
it's hard to be in relationship with
somebody with borderline it's hard it's
hard to love somebody that's that is
um so back and forth all the time right
you know that and or it's hard to
so deeply in love and to get hit in the
face or to be told I I can't breathe
without you that's how much I love you
and then 30 minutes later it's like I
hate you right it's hard
um yet it is so powerful and so I've got
a special place in my in my heart for
folks uh who are struggling with this
and my oldest
friend on planet Earth is a TBI Survivor
a traumatic brain injury Survivor and so
I've got a heart for that so
um I'm grateful for you for for your
trust and I'm more so than that I'm
really grateful that you're going to
call today and get somebody that's going
to walk alongside you get a whole team
um it's Inpatient time and we're gonna
go spend some time getting some rest and
getting the help that we need I'm
grateful for you Lynn we'll be right
back
hey guys deloney here listen I get
questions about sleep all the time on my
show and man we have so distorted our
perception of sleep either we pretend
we've evolved past it and I'll sleep
when I'm dead or we over complicate it
and think we need a million products and
pills and anything to get sleep and
sleep is important it's crucial to your
mental and physical health but there are
so many simple things you can do like go
to bed and get up at the same time every
day kill the electronics an hour before
bed and make sure you've got a great
mattress this is one product I do
recommend investing in for Quality sleep
and that's why I love dream Cloud their
mattresses are made with Advanced
Technologies to keep you comfortable all
night for a great price and right now
dream cloud is offering 25 off any
mattress plus 599 dollars in accessories
and an additional 50 discount with code
John deloney it's one word so go to
dreamcloudsleep.com manager promo code
John deloney to get your new mattress
today
all right all right let's go to Ava in
Richmond Virginia what's up Ava
Hi how are you I am most excellent how
are you
I am
well I think I'm good
so you're not good it's okay to say it
what's up
um so my question is
um as you know the holidays you're
dealing with families
in-laws and um
we had a trip with my in-laws and um
and I've been with my uh
husband for uh we're gonna be 18 years
in Feb No 19 years from February
congratulations together forever thank
you thank you he's my
we have two kids
and I mean we've been through
so much together and um you're about to
say he's your what
he's my high school sweetheart
um
I'm sorry but it's it is what it is I
met him in high school that's love I
love it I love it I love it and
um so
I
fell in love with him and all this stuff
because he's he's a really good I think
he's a good person but um you know
throughout our relationship we've sort
of had issues with my mother-in-law's
not really nice woman
um and I was really I'm I was when I
first started I was saying a very nice I
uh in my culture you know and I think in
a lot of cultures but
um
they're very big on respecting Elders
like it's a very
like it's it's very like it's very big
what's your culture
I'm Ethiopian okay
um and so it's very big in in that in
that aspect and so when I met his mom
she would just be the meanest evilest
person in the world and you know I come
give me an example
an example is
um
I came home and I was living with her
I came home from finding out that um I'm
adopted by the way so having a family is
very big for me and my um I came home
that I found out that I was um I was
already four months pregnant I knew that
I was happy but I was having issues and
I came home and I lived with her and she
stood there and she speaks a different
language from me but um
she stood there in front of my husband
and said you know you killed the baby
right and I could understand at that
time because I've been with him about
two years so I could understand Spanish
um so sorry I'm so sorry
I mean that that's that's like the next
thing
but um
I was fluctuating with my weight and
depression and you know
um
of uh and all these things and so
um she would just say like oh you're too
fat for my son or she would say like
um just a lot of mean things just
and my husband saw it like he where is
he in all this
he just didn't say anything he said
that's just my mom and she'll stop
sister hey but dude he needs to step up
man oh so he's definitely you know he's
um a coward
yeah yeah yeah so no dude
he's a coward he's the first boy he's
the first boy she's um Hey listen I
could care less I'm the first boy in my
house
yeah well his father is not in his life
so I feel like listen if my mom said
that to my to my wife
when I was in his wife at that time
you're about to be the mom of his baby
yeah but he allowed it and he's
continued to allow it
and he's continued to allow it oh yeah
but you know over time I sort of what he
wanted is for me to stand up to her and
so that was a little bit oh that's his
job it's his mom
I know so that was a little bit
um that was the most difficult because
in my culture you're not even supposed
to like
come to an like someone that's older
than you in that aspect and so I
continued to sort of put my head there's
a cultural aspect 100 you you honor you
honor
um
Elders to the end of time you get on you
go down to the bottom of the ocean on
that ship I get that
yeah there's also something you're not
admitting to yourself and that is your
husband is leaving you out to dry
oh yeah I would I would tell him that if
he was on the phone I wish he was on the
phone because I don't like talking about
people
but there's another room I can get him
for you he has got to
say Mom we are not coming to your house
anymore
because of how you talk to my wife the
mother of my children
conversation ends
and then we'd get over it I wouldn't
talk to her and I would stand up for
myself and he's like good job you're
standing up for yourself and and you
know me like I said I'm a doctor I I was
in so many years of my life where I was
not protected by anyone and I didn't
need anyone to protect me but I felt
sort of yes you did we all do we all do
I do I we all do we all do
we do
still do but um okay so what happened do
you have a big blow up did you go to war
so my mother-in-law we want we want her
to be with us because me and my husband
we when we traveled we're like hey we
have an extra room you can stay in that
room you have your own bed your kitchen
everything awesome and she was fine and
then like when her other kids start
coming
she sort of like tends to take things
out on me because I'm easy to take out
on you know I'm not related to her so
it's easy to be mean to me and so she
would just say certain things like oh
you know like I love to cook I love to
like I just you know I wanna I'm very
um
I think one of the things my husband
maybe doesn't like about me is that I'm
very
I think about others a little too much
and maybe I don't think about myself
um but I I was like you know that's
probably because he loves you and cares
about you and watches you
you know drive yourself into the ground
trying to be a peacekeeper right
all right go to it go to it we're
getting up against the clock go to it no
okay so what happened is um we had a big
blow up
ever I said something and I um I
disrespected my husband in front of her
what'd you say um and then I said
I said it's really bad I said
I Am The Unlucky dumbass being with you
and uh that sounds like Kelly says that
to me all the time well his mother said
something in regards of
I didn't want to curse but um I already
did but she sort of said
um you know you're she said I don't want
this
b-i-t-c-h to talk about my son or treat
my son like this now mind you I
I take I think me personally out of
anyone that they know they know my
husband their their brother their son is
treated better than their own house they
know that like I I believe everyone in
the family knows he is taking care of
but this is somebody who is yes was what
you said mean yeah it's fine
that's somebody who is looking for any
tiny tiny little crack yes yes to just
blow right through it to knock the whole
building down
yes so she so so the whole thing is that
like I would say this if my wife said
that about me in front of my my dad my
mom uh-huh they would laugh and they
would say yep nah okay I just want I
want to give you some other contacts my
parents are great people my parents love
me dearly
but they also trust my wife implicitly
yeah like a daughter not like some weird
like tumor that's been added on to our
family
okay so that's how she treats me how can
I how can I help
so my thing is the whole blow up
happened it got physical because she
pushed me Oh I pushed her back I am Gina
yeah okay
we were it was I've never touched like
it was really bad anyways my issue is
throughout the trip my husband and me
discussed it and I said hey you have to
protect me you have to put a pause on
your mom even the sisters were telling
him like be careful with my like
everybody knew and so my question is how
do I I told them from now on I don't
want his mom in my life correct that's
just it I don't want her in my life I
just don't think I know how to respond
when someone attacks let me say that let
me say let me say it this way for you
yes your your mother-in-law has opted
out of your life
because you owe Ava safety
and you owe Ava peace
and you owe a of a dignity and respect
and this person I don't care if she is a
stranger somebody at the bus stop or
your mother-in-law
has chosen
to physically assault you to disrespect
you to take your dignity away from you
to make you feel less than on a regular
basis to prop herself up in her place in
her firstborn son's life
and so you're not kicking her out of
nothing
yeah she has chosen to not be a part of
your life because she doesn't treat you
like a human being
full stop
so I don't want you walking around with
the burden of guilt
and don't let your husband put that on
well we can't go because you won't be
around mama no
your mom has what do I do then like for
my son and my daughter like the great
Jay-Z says you brush your shoulders off
and go on to the next
she's like what do I do if it's family
events sweet if she chooses to if the
rest of the family chooses to have her
there then they are choosing to not have
you there and that's fine
that means don't go if she goes there
don't go there why would you go there I
don't know anymore to experience
violence to experience disrespect and
listen you're teaching your kids
yeah that's the sad part your husband is
teaching your kids hey when somebody
attacks your mother or my wife we just
keep going back for more we just keep
going back for more I don't say nothing
that's her problem
so I should just like for the relation
how do I stay out of the relationship
between because I've never been I've
always said hey Juan you know um
sorry hey Don can you please contact
your mom can you please um call your mom
and see how she's doing nope he is if he
chooses to have a relationship with her
great that's wonderful
um
unless it's not right I mean if he
forgets her birthday that's a choice
he's made
you're not his mommy
yeah so stop stop pushing that that's
how yeah I mean here ultimately it's a
it's a non-confrontational I'm not
fighting anybody
okay I'm gonna tell my husband I'm gonna
tell my wife
hey I just want I'm I'm drawing
boundaries you've told me that this is
my fight for my whole life you've never
stepped up to help me out so I've I'm
choosing how I'm ending this fight
I will not go to events if if with with
your mother there
she's she is chosen to
um
not be around me and so she's not gonna
be around my kids
I can't tell you what to do you're a
grown man if you want to go to family
get-togethers and whatever you're
welcome to do that my kids
um I don't feel safe with him there
I don't want to hurt anyone I just this
is a little girl who's still wondering
why her mom and dad
Center away
yeah
Ava you were loved
so it's okay then to say to and it's not
mean if I tell my husband hey you know I
you can go but my kids are gonna I don't
feel safe with my kids being with her
absolutely even if my kids want to go
your job my kids want to eat donuts 24 7
365. my job as a parent is that's not
safe right it's not good their insides
will melt it's like it's it's it's
that's my job as a parent
my son wants to go ride four-wheelers
he's not gonna do that he's you know
what I mean like it's not safe and so
it's my job and so yes
there is a hun a hundred percent every
reason to believe
that the animosity and hatred that that
woman has displayed to
the wife of her son
uh-huh will be transferred to your kids
absolutely yeah
absolutely yes
no question about it I also think it's
very very fair
and it might not be the season but it is
very fair
okay to tell your husband
that you're heartbroken that he never
stood up for you
heartbroken
she's not talking to him either because
she because she's a child she said she's
a child she is a spoiled brat child
period yeah she's not talking to him
because uh she said he didn't even stand
up for me he said to her you're making
my life difficult and she said oh my God
he told her that and when he told her
that she got so upset and said how can
you go against me
you know I am your mother how can you go
against me and he told her I'm not going
against you the kids told me you put
your hands on my wife and then and then
also hurt the little there was a little
girl involved that she hurt and so I was
defending and so even to yesterday I
asked I said are you upset at me you
know because we're having huge issues
now and he's like no I'm not I'm not
upset at you because you defended
yourself from my mother I knew my mother
was going to do that to you I I knew
when I walked away knowing that
and to me I guess with that that breaks
my heart that breaks my heart for Him
man
yeah I wish he just sort of I wish you
could just speak to me like
like all I want from my husband is just
to say I have not defended you all this
time and protected you as what it should
have been my duty I said hey have you
said that to him because it's in there
now you've not said that out loud before
have you
to him so many times and it has been
ears and so maybe he left you he's left
you to defend yourself great I'm not
going anymore yeah and I want you to
um
this is gonna be something that you
practice but I want you to
say that with peace in your heart
I want you to say that with joy and
optimism me and the kids we're going to
a water park
we're going to stay in a hotel we're
going to have pizza and movies and just
be ridiculous for 48 hours that's what
we're gonna do you I would love love for
you to join us
but if you want to go there that's great
it's disgusting and disrespectful for a
in-law to put themself between their
child and their child's spouse
yeah it's it's the it's one of the
lowest forms of immaturity because that
should be a relationship that parents
should be championing and cheering for
and lifting up
so glad that you of all people picked my
son and I wouldn't have picked you for
him I think you're weird I think you're
not the right culture I think you're not
the right one Whatever religion but my
son picked you and I raised a good guy I
trust him
and so he picked you
we pick you we're all in
that's how that should be and it should
be every single thing I can do to lift
you guys up
yeah not everything I can do to get
between you two I need to remember I'm
the mom here no dude no it's wrong it's
wrong it's wrong Ava and you're not the
crazy one for two decades you have not
been the crazy one
okay is it is it um
bad
or is it wrong that I throughout this
whole time you know I I thought about
her like I actually thought about like
how is she doing no you're looking at
the hotel like listen listen listen for
her stop thinking that your feelings are
bad or wrong
they just are yeah
yeah okay what you what you choose to
meditate on
yeah if you go down a roll like a rabbit
hole like I just want the worst for her
I would say that's no that's not right
you know what I mean or if you opposite
I know I know I'm just saying more for
her or if you choose to start sending
her emails from a secret account just to
harass her that's your actions aren't
right okay your thoughts and actions you
can judge those your feelings they just
come man they come and you have never
had permission to feel
yeah and so yeah dude you if you if
that's the kind of person you are oh
gosh I wish we had more Hearts like
yours did somebody hurt you and on their
way out you wonder hope they're okay
oh there I hope they're okay
[Music]
that's that's pouring heaping holes on
the head of your enemy man like because
you you literally hope no it's not bad
it's not good
it's probably not wise to then call and
reach out and try to repair that
relationship as though you did something
wrong because you didn't
yeah you popped off about about her son
who cares it's not worth physical
violence it's not worth hurting a little
kid
you're good
you're good and maybe for the first time
this is a season how about this I want
you to get a journal I want you to start
writing able letters
but I feel what you're worth
what you wish had happened and more
importantly what you need going forward
and these can be some awkward hard
conversation with your husband but
you need him not to leave you out on an
island
emotionally or physically
y'all are in this thing together
thanks for trusting us thanks for giving
your call we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show me
I want to thank you all so much for
being with us today uh don't forget
subscribe pass it along like thumbs up
whatever else
um hey follow me on Instagram too at
John deloney
d-e-l-o-n-y uh I never thought I would
say those words out loud but I just did
follow me on the internet at Instagram
today's song of the day I was singing it
walking into the booth today
it just so happens that the first call
was asking the same thing the song's by
Foreigner Kelly does not have this
tattoo
I won't lie about it
song is I want to know what love is and
it goes like this I gotta take a little
time a little time to think things over
a better read between the lines in case
I need it when I'm older I don't know
what that means now this mountain I must
climb feels like a world upon my
shoulders through the clouds I'll see
Love Shine it keeps me warm as life
grows colder
in my life there's been heartache and
pain I don't know if I can face it again
I don't want to know what love is I want
you to show me
I want to feel What Love Is
I know
I know that's it all right hey I love
y'all see you soon
[Music]